he's got a
gun palor dubbed Pokemon with guns
became the third most played game ever
on Steam in less than a week so you
might be wondering howed up can it be
well aside from letting you use your
Pets As Weapons grenade launchers and
flamethrowers this weird game lets you
capture creatures and humans which you
can then sell on the black market I
could sell a human for
$562 selling humans is the metal don't
like your newfound human or non-human
pets well you can butcher them and sell
the meat
yeah never mind never mind you can
butcher the human want to create your
own sweat shop with creatures as your
workers you can do that too but it's
also become a controversial game since
Beyond its weird premise it borrows
heavily from Pokemon itself remember how
you were lazy bro remember
that ah